hi guys it's me Eric and I am coming to
you live live kind of it's like I'm
coming to you live sort of from a
vacation destination that has too much
fun life the reason I'm making this
though is that there are a lot of
exciting things happening at new rock
stars and me and the team felt like it
was time to fill you in in fact you
might have seen our channel banner
teasing this all month long so the
purpose of this video is to share with
you some really important updates but
also and I'm really excited about this
it's to get some ideas from you all
about where we should take some of these
things stick around the end of this
video to find out how you can share some
of your ideas with us but up first one
of our big announcements we've been
trying really hard to make this happen
and I'm really excited to tell you that
Phillip Molina is coming back beemo
himself Wow
stupid you might know him as the guy
with the hat or who knows you might not
know him at all but don't worry it's not
like I'm going anywhere and Phillip is
really great actually was him who quasi
founded this version of new rockstars
and started this whole business of
breakdowns that we know and love but
Phillips not the only person being added
to the team and those aren't the only
announcements but I'll let Phillip
explain and I'll be back in the indoors
where I belong very soon but for now
take it away Phillip hey guys I'm Melana
it has been a while like my name down
there yes I know it is felt awful who
cares I am back the nondenominational
holiday miracle we did it okay
I'm gonna be totally genuine before I
say anything else I absolutely have to
thank these complete badasses who have
been taking care of this channel Eric
and Erickson it honestly it just means
so much to me like I feel like I owe you
guys everything guys this channel felt
like my baby I go be it yes a baby that
I accidentally sort of left on the bus
and I could be charged with all sorts of
neglect for but don't worry about that
now look at what you've grown you're so
big
some of the million of you that's
amazing I remember when we to shoot this
thing in my apartment and my dog Kyle Oh
edited for free now in the interest of
full disclosure I have to admit I never
totally left new rock stars I mean how
could I it was literally still shot in
my apartment
so pretty recently but now that I am
fully back all the way in
maximum effort I am just so incredibly
happy you have no idea how much I miss
you guys
seriously you there you I have been out
in the real world it's not awesome but
you guys the audience you are the most
intelligent kind audience on YouTube
getting to talk about nerdy stuff with
you all is an absolute privilege and
coming back here was a complete
no-brainer because of you so thank you
but enough emotions they clash with my
programming back to announcement lately
new rock stars has been getting provided
with a bunch of opportunities that are
completely game-changing like over the
years it always toward me and Eric up
when we would get tweets from you all
asking us to give our opinion on
something cool or like an awesome nerdy
thing would happen and then we just
would not have the bandwidth to talk
about it or by the time we could that
thing was long gone but now the channel
is really getting to a place where the
growth acne phase of its puberty is like
almost done either it's coming really
close to the oh so exciting growth spurt
that's been awaiting this has been gross
you guys might have noticed that in the
past couple of weeks we've been
experimenting with more videos and
really we're just trying to get ready
for a situation where we can start doing
more and more content like the eventual
goal is to make stuff for you all daily
that is so huge for us
risa strong going to get one video up
per week it's that but also one thing
I've learned is that groin pain suck
when you go through them alone so get
ready because I want you to go through
them with us I've seen other channels
really struggle through periods of
growth and I feel like that's been
because of two reasons one they stop
doing the stuff that everyone loved
about the channel in order to start
doing the new stuff and two they didn't
ask the audience of what new stuff they
wanted so here's my pledge to you the
breakdown and analysis videos are not
going away and there's not going to be
less of them either they can't go away
they are literally how my brain works
but the new content I want you to help
us come up with it and here's the thing
I said it earlier you're the smartest
audience I've ever encountered
so I'm going to give you some real
transparency here yes we're growing and
yes
ideal content ad would be even more
breakdowns and analysis videos they're
addictive as hell and we love making
them but we can't look at least not
without having breakdowns ourselves the
research the writing the editing no lie
I seriously worked 100 hours a week I'm
not kidding
when I was trying to get those breakdown
videos out and get maybe one out so
again I'm going to reiterate we're not
replacing the breakdowns we're not
looking to do less of them but the new
ideas for show format so we're looking
for things that we can realistically do
in a sustainable non-suicidal way like
we just don't want to die that's all so
here's how you can tell us your ideas we
made a poll you can find the link at the
top of the description I'm also going to
throw it in the comments and it has some
ideas for some show formats that we
think could work but it'll also most
importantly have a fill-in-the-blank
option for any idea you have and hell
it's also like it's a great place to
leave feedback in general I'm really
excited about getting you all involved
in the decision-making process because I
genuinely respect your opinions but also
because we're going to start doing that
really regularly like I don't want to
make videos about topics that you guys
don't care about so we're going to find
a system for you guys to just tell us
what you care about right now sound
familiar
actually if any of you like programming
geniuses I think it'd be really cool if
you found some way to just like send
people to a website and they're like
type in what they want and it somehow
becomes like a cool bar graph and it
solves data and like numbers and I love
that stuff that I'm just realizing I'm
outing myself as a data nerd cool just
okay I get on the poll please
we are really eager to start rolling out
new ideas so let's start coming up with
them now before I wrap this up there's
actually one more thing remember I don't
want it to die making more content well
I got a plan for that we're going to get
Ericsson some help editing I think kylo
is available but his rates are also
through the roof so we'll see but we
also can't spread Eric too thin either
so we're adding some new hosts and while
we're still talking all sorts of great
people I want to tell you about to
specifically Maude Garrett and Sam
batcher I met both of them during my
time at SourceFed nerd rest in peace and
we just clicked so damn well and guys if
you don't know them don't worry we
didn't do some casting call these two
are experts in all things nerdy and they
are the real deal Sam has an awesome
Podcast called only stupid answers that
you have to check out is so incredibly
nerdy you're gonna love it
and then Maude check out her own channel
it's called geek bomb and you'll see
she's incredibly legit she's the most
legit she might even be a bigger fan of
Game of Thrones than I am I mean
probably not but maybe maybe we should
do a show together about it I don't know
let us know in the pool now again yes we
are talking to other great people too
about joining us on camera but I hope
you can tell how excited I am because I
think you should be too this wasn't some
corporation putting together a nerdy boy
band so that is a brilliant idea
Eric has been my best friend for over a
decade Maude and Sam are like our
kindred spirits except they're like
significantly cooler than we are I just
can't wait for you guys to get to know
them but also maybe through them get to
know us better too like sometimes I feel
like Eric and I maybe come off as boring
history teachers or something and that's
not totally who we are for more like the
kind of cool substitute teacher who
doesn't technically have a degree in
education but still finds some way to
justify like playing cool movies during
class and kind of connecting it to the
lesson actually the guy I'm thinking of
got fired but anyway I'm really excited
I hope you are too and if you're nervous
I know change can be scary and I know
more content could theoretically mean
like a dip in quality but do not worry I
am seriously obsessed with quality and
doing just the best damn job that we can
do like seriously like like to obsess
okay Thank You Eriksen anyway I can't
wait to hear all your ideas jump in the
poll I also can't wait to make all of
the nerdy stuff for you also if you
somehow ended up in this video and you
do know who Maude and Sam are but you
don't know what the heck the channel is
welcome source said fan don't worry I
think you're really going to like it
here but I'll throw up some videos that
you can check out of the kind of stuff
we make I think it's all great also stay
tuned there's a ton of cool stuff I
didn't have time to even talk about in
this video
so just thank you so much seriously it's
good to be home